sabías que podemos crear círculos a
partir de 123 puntos o una línea es
sorprendente
veamos cómo transformar estos simples
puntos y rayas en circunferencias
saca una hoja lápiz y tu juego de
geometría para que vayamos haciéndolo
juntos si no lo tienes con mucha
atención para que puedas hacerlo después
empecemos con algo muy sencillo si
queremos convertir una línea en una
circunferencia es muy fácil lo único que
tenemos que hacer es poner la aguja de
nuestro compás en un extremo de la línea
la punta del lápiz en el otro extremo y
trazamos la circunferencia perfecto
ahora pongamos un punto en cualquier
parte de la hoja para trazar una
circunferencia que pase justo por ahí
tomo tu compás ábrelo del tamaño que
quieras y coloca la punta del lápiz
sobre el punto que dibujamos coloca la
aguja en cualquier punto de preferencia
al centro de la hoja para que nuestro
círculo quepa completamente y no se
salga de la hoja sujeta tu compás y gira
los 360 grados es decir da un giro
completo mira cómo lo hago recuerda que
esta aguja nos sirve para darle apoyo al
compás así que trata de no moverla listo
ya dibujamos nuestro círculo ves cómo
pasa por el punto inicial fue muy fácil
únicamente tenemos que saber usar bien
el compás crees que sea el único círculo
que podemos crear a partir de ese punto
no si ponemos nuestro compás en otra
parte de la hoja y trazamos otro círculo
también este va a pasar por el mismo
punto veamos cómo
fíjate como dependiendo de dónde
coloques la aguja podemos generar
infinidad de círculos que pasen por el
mismo punto cada uno puede tener un
radio diferente dependiendo de cuánto
abramos el compás
pon atención para ver cómo podemos crear
circunferencias a partir de dos puntos
dibujemos dos puntos en cualquier
espacio de la hoja tratando de que
queden al centro
ahora coloca tu regla y traza una línea
que une a los puntos mide la distancia
entre ellos y divide la la mitad para
encontrar el punto medio
saca tu escuadra para trazar una línea
perpendicular a la línea que se forma
entre los dos puntos
después quita la escuadra y con la regla
es la línea más larga justo así con la
aguja del compás sobre cualquier parte
de la línea perpendicular que acabamos
de dibujar y ábrelo para que la punta
del lápiz toque uno de los puntos verás
como al trazar la circunferencia pasará
por ambos puntos mientras más acerquemos
la aguja al punto medio la
circunferencia será más pequeña y
mientras más se aleje será más grande
coloca la aguja exactamente en el punto
medio abre el compás para que la punta
del lápiz pase por alguno de los dos
puntos y dibuja una circunferencia justo
así en este círculo que acabamos de
dibujar el centro coincide con la línea
original que une los puntos así que esa
línea se convertirá en un diámetro
para los círculos que se tracen a lo
largo de la línea vertical y que su
centro no coincida con el de los dos
puntos esa misma línea será una cuerda
si te fijaste bien el diámetro de un
círculo es el que pasa por el centro y
la cuerda es la que toca dos puntos del
círculo pero no pasa por el centro wow
qué divertido pero hay algo todavía más
sorprendente dibujemos tres puntos que
no estén alineados ni muy separados mira
cómo es importante que ubiquemos cuál es
el punto medio entre estos tres puntos
como lo haremos con tu compás traza
círculos del mismo tamaño alrededor de
cada punto y busca que se toquen entre
sí
toma tu regla y traza una línea recta
que atraviese las intersecciones entre
los círculos un tip deben de ser tres
rayas porque tenemos tres círculos y
quedaría algo así coloca tu compás
apoyando la aguja en donde cruzan las
tres líneas o sea en el punto medio y
dibuja con la punta del lápiz la
circunferencia iniciando en uno de los
tres puntos
al pasar por un punto automáticamente
pasará por los otros dos puntos te lo
aseguro te invito a que sigas formando
círculos con 1 2 o 3 puntos y rayas